hello my name is Barry Barclay i would
like to describe the close to that I've
interviewed to his lab boots confidence
I began the study thinking about the
five current models of breath
carcinogenesis the somatic mutation
model the epigenetic model the
aneuploidy model the tissue field
organization model the bioenergetic
model and the metabolic your programming
model to my mind all of these had
significant support in the literature
but they were held to be by most
students in this area as mutually
exclusive I thought there was enough
support for each one that probably is
not the case so I began thinking about a
simplifying and unifying model based
upon my work and others that one of the
common themes of these models was a
perturbation of primitive nucleotide
metabolism if you would have a look at
figure 5 I will start there this is an
experiment i did in yeast over 20 years
ago in sacramento cerevisiae this is a
cdc 21 weakened and the it's an ox
atrophic armadyl eight and if a high
concentration of thymidylate was within
the center of the plate it would
establish the radial gradient too low
and near zero periphery I was struggle
and the plate is overlaid with peppers
oleum is to score for respiratory
competence which are red and those cells
which are introductory deficient or wait
if we start at the periphery of the play
the first thing you notice is cells are
enviable and I know that's interesting
if the tens gene itself which is
exquisitely regulated in human cells
were to be turned down you would get a
tumors of very mixed character to be
heterogeneous and on set with respect to
clones of loss of viability and those
which had unstable genomes both in the
nucleus and then mitochondria if you
look at the middle of this plate those
in respiratory progression cells where
the cyma delete concentration is optimum
and about that is the zone of intense
mutagenesis i should say low TMP
strangely enough is not very mutagenic
at all for nuclear genes but very
mutagenic from mitochondria hi TMP
results in very strong mutagenesis for
both nucleus and the mitochondrion but a
different kind at the YouTube genomes so
if we now step back and have a look at
how we do supply to breast cancer well I
made the leap that this would be a model
system of stem cells in which the gene
for TM cards thymidylate synthase
located at 18 p 11 dot 32 if that were
challenged by environmental insult or
nutritional deficiencies or inherited
genes like Braca wanna bracket 2 b's
cells would no longer be able to repair
double strand breaks for Trisha's so you
have
Oh genic and recombinant genetic events
that give rise to the three types of
extracellular elements that I've
described in figs two three and four
what these figures revealed to me was
that when you have this kind of
instability for example in figure 2 we
have a hairpin pound room I'm sorry
Tracy I got the wrong career that's Isis
cytochrome 18 can I back up on that one
figure 3 is a hairpin palindrome and
interestingly it would give rise to a
heterogeneous population cells due to
the instability of the tims encoding
pound room as it would be extruded in an
exosome so now we have a feature that
has seen in breast cancer and later than
these 18 chromosome 18 manas on when
amplified it would give rise to I
suppose the same kind of events that
occur in yeast hi thymidylate so that
type of cytogenetic events would give
rise to a strong mutator phenotype both
for the nucleus and the mitochondria the
consequences of the mitochondrial
mutations are not only the spy Rotarians
efficiency Warburg effect but also
because the mitochondrion is intimately
involved in intrinsic a proptosis
cascade mediated by p63 these cells
would become increasingly tolerant of
more aberrant genomic events in the
nucleus similarly with the circle on 64
it would be very similar interestingly
the generation of this circle by this
kind of cytogenetic event unrepaired
damaged proximal and distal to 1811 dot
32 these kind of X chromosome elements
will be highly unstable it will give
rise to transforming exosomes bicycle
and also because they are palindromic
circles it would be excellent substrates
for recombination into the nuclear
genome so they'd be unstable both in
terms of their location if they were
ectopic they would behave like X
chromosome 11 but they could also
integrate into the chromosome and form
more stable lines within the same tumor
and lastly figure 6 summarizes what I
tried to think about that this model
that I've worked on for 25 years now
attempted to accommodated least
essential elements of the present areas
of carcinogenesis in addition so that if
you look at figure 6 there are a number
of events that will occur by tims being
either expressed at a high level or low
low and the last comment I would make
about that summary is it interestingly
as well as accommodating essential
elements of those theory also the build
up of either deoxy or delete or deoxys
time and delete would give rise to the
angiogenic factors reaction rivals one
phosphate and deoxyribose so these cells
would be angiogenic
and I think I'll end there and thank you
very much for your kind attention